donnez-nous cinq minutes mesdames et
messieurs vous allez tout comprendre cet
enjeu qui peut paraître complexe parce
que le mode de financement de ces
organismes là et complexes nicolas behra
re bonsoir lise bourgault directrice de
mais l'arrêt que bonsoir à vous
reprenons depuis le début
tous vos problèmes ont commencé quand le
gouvernement en fait des changements à
l'aide sociale on a coupé le chèque des
gens qui allaient pour des thérapies
fermé de 700 quelques $ à 200 $
auparavant vous nous l'expliquer à vous
les bénéficiaires vous donnait une
grosse partie de ce chèque là pour payer
pour l'heure leur séjour ceux qui ne
peuvent plus faire et nous donner 400
dollars pour payer pour les frais de
thérapie parce que les traits de séjour
sont assumés et par le ministère de
l'emploi de la solidarité sociale et on
leur demandait également une somme de
150 $ pour des frais d'admission
tout ça mis ensemble depuis le 1er mai
me fait perdre trois cent cinquante
mille dollars
j'ai ensuite les arguments puisque jeu
on est mal gérée très bien la ministre
dit hier monsieur bédard vous avez une
vue d'ensemble miss a dit comment ça se
fait monsieur roy qui a des cendres qui
vont très bien plus à descendre comme
mais la rich qui vont très mal un autre
exemple provient de donner aussi
répondre à cette question là pourquoi
dix ans vont bien d'autres vont mal les
monsieur roy est assez simple mais nice
la ministre de la santé au verset bon
hamada 3.7 millions à 15 organismes qui
avaient uniquement 95 lits on donne des
subventions on paie des lits inoccupés
ce qu'on a à faire à la menace ces deux
pays par tête de pipe père les occuper
mais si tu as deux catégories ya deux
catégories d'îles il ya des maisons qui
sont pleinement subventionnés qui est
peu importe des gens dedans ils
reçoivent le même montant puis à
d'autres maisons comme mais l'afrique et
d'autres qui sont moins beaucoup moins
subventionnés absolument à titre
d'exemple wade les maisons commun qui
font partie de l'association des
organismes indépendants ce dont je suis
leurs représentants on communique
subvention de 49 euros par jour dans
l'autre côté on retrouve des centres qui
reçoivent une subvention annuelle
récurrente
bon an mal an indépendamment du nombre
de lits occupés
qui plus est ces centres là on doit en
plus aux 49 dollar par jour donc on a
deux catégories de santons ne les
centres qui ont largement du financement
et les autres qui sont des centres com -
comme nos e mails avec quino qui ne vaut
rien est ce qu'on peut dire que les
centres comme vous l'aimez l'arrêt parce
que vous êtes responsable d'un centre
vhu agréé des l'envolée qui est très
reconnue aussi est-ce que vos centres à
vous s'adresse à une clientèle encore
plus difficile encore plus poké passez
moi l'expression absolument alors nous
on accueille les citoyens les clients
qui arrivent peu importe qui joue à
l'aide sociale ou pau la plupart des
clients qui arrivent similaires et que
monsieur roi lion rien et on pas de 4,2
sur le social on peut se satisfaire de
de citoyenneté on s'occupe de ce set à
patty 250 $ qu'on leur charge et on leur
demandait de ne payer sur quatre mois je
voudrais vous dire que c'est des 600
emplois en plus les emplois dans la
chute et ce sans point avec les centres
le parallèle qui sont perdus dans une
petite région comme enchanté qu'est ce
que vous demandez au gouvernement que
vous soyez tous traités de la même façon
tu vois c'est ce qu'on a présenté à la
menace au mois de novembre on y avait
des tableaux et on doit la menace plane
la menace
donnez-nous 10 dollars par jour et vous
assurer le service en toxicomanie pour
l'ensemble du québec
qui plus est on s'engage à aller
chercher les gens de qui nous appellent
le lundi soir le dimanche soir dans la
nuit dans les hôpitaux on va vous offrir
un service encore plus poussée et ça va
vous coûter encore moins cher on va
soulager réseau de la santé vous avez eu
des rencontres avec des souligné vettel
à québec plusieurs fois pourquoi selon
vous le gouvernement n'accepte pas ce
partenariat
on nous dit constamment qu'on est en
période d'austérité que le gouvernement
n'a pas d'argent ce qui peut se passer
de cendres comme
comme le centre malgré tout comme
d'autres centres au québec en disant
avoir seulement besoin de 602 on juge
que l'on jugeait et on juge que trop de
lits disponibles parce que c'est vrai
que trop de lits disponibles
non non il est pas trop d'hispania
laissant comme et l'afrique qui
accueille et qui enquête
particulièrement difficile là faut pas
se le cacher bien nous on les accueille
on leur donne des services peu importe
mais c'est demander trop à un organisme
sans but lucratif que de s'occuper de
ces personnes notions besoin dead c'est
pas ma responsabilité monsieur roy moi
je veux bien assumer mais que le
gouvernement ne donne une équité de
financement qui me rembourse que ce que
j'ai vu de plus 1er mai et qui me donne
10 pièces par jour
générique je serais restée ouverte à six
mois que saab solo ils peuvent pas dit
que ça lui arrive de yair l'eau est-ce
que depuis trois jours je le disais il
ya eu beaucoup de réactions est ce que
j'avais un appel d'un sous ministre des
mines et c'est ce que quelqu'un déjà
plaint déjà on voit ça soir on va faire
le point sur tout ça est ce que je suis
pas prêt à envoyer une lettre au premier
ministre où on en reviendrait au premier
ce mardi matin on a eu copie conforme au
docteur barrette madame charlebois
monsieur amable j'ai eu un appel rejeté
une adjointe au cabinet de madame
charlebois on me dit que notre demande
d'un système nous on est ouvert à
s'asseoir on est ouverts à négocier on
est ouverts à trouver un terrain
d'entente on est ouvert à tous on est
ouvert à tous on veut pas se faire
amener à québec puisse faire dit on n'a
pas d'argent où on va regarder ça on va
analyser ça ça fait près d'un an qu'on
est en demande soit près d'un an qu'on
monte des dossiers qu'on envoie des
appels qu'on se concerte ils savent
pertinemment qu'on n'arrivait pop qu'on
en viendrait à ce point d'eau le
protecteur du citoyen avait averti la
ministre que le 200 d'alors était
nettement insuffisant et qu'il risque à
avoir un bris de service lors ce
qu'encore une fois on se vous vous
adressez et vous donner les services
vraiment aux gens qui ont les plus
vulnérables la société québécoise mais
des prisonniers dans certains cas des
gens qui essaient de refaire leur vie
ici plus difficile pour vos organismes
d'aller chercher de l'argent sur la
place publique
c'est pas une clientèle qui est
politiquement très rentable c'est dire
est ce que c'est le contraire au début
quand il ya eu les coupures au mois de
mai on a senti que la population la
population celle là fait que plus ou
moins puis ça les dérangeait pas trop si
on touchait pas trop on touchait pas
trop à la bien mais on se rend compte
que plus les fermetures la rive plus les
citoyens commencent à être appelés on a
des parents qui vient de porter les
enfants dans nos ressources et puis qui
commence à voir qu'il ya des pics à des
problématiques qui a découpé le service
à titre d'exemple il ya des centres qui
avaient des programmes de scolarisation
mais les riques en avait un
on en avait volé il ya d'autres centres
au québec un nom on a coupé le regard de
scolarisation vous devez couper votre
podium on accompagnait les résidents les
commissions scolaires par une hôtesse
d'expérience on avait croyez le ou non à
un taux de succès de 50% hôtesses
d'équivalent de secondaire 5 vous auriez
dû voir le visage de nos pensionnaires
26 normes par des postes incroyable on a
coupé son on a demandé une admission
le ministre sam hamad aujourd'hui il
n'est pas l'heure on n'a pas voulu faire
d'autre commentaire
on nous a dit que ce que madame
charlebois d'hier c'était la réponse
pour l'instant du gouvernement on verra
est-ce que ça bougera envers en tout cas
on va suivre parce que j'aime ciel alesi
oui j'espère beaucoup que la décision
est brutale et est difficile douloureuse
de belgique de fermer sepa va aider des
centres comme l'envolée et d'autres
centres il faut convaincre le
gouvernement que lors la digue et et et
comment quand tu pourrais de meurtre est
ouverte
il faut que ça soit un électrochoc et
les électrochocs pour que on se lève et
condition que la bd remercie lise
bourgault
merci beaucoup on va suivre ça d'aussi
alors mesdames et messieurs vous avez
été nombreux à nous écrire je voulais
redonne ses adresses les voici
on vous lit avec beaucoup d'attention
voilà